[Musique]
dis mon ami Angelo a traîné la savate
dans les petites rues
chantabou parmi les murs tout blancs
quand le soleil éclate écrasant la CB et
déchant le BL Marie demi il disait que
le Nord commençait juste après les tours
de Carcasson et le voilà jeté par le
coquin de
[Musique]
s ma
patrie j'ai tout laissé là-bas quand
j'ai fait la valise mais comme les
autres il
[Musique]
ditentallah parole d'honneur mon frère
c'est de tout quitter abandonnant la
terre où tavais tant
semé
soleil soleil de mon pays si beau tu
fais rien que tomber en morceau la purée
de nous autres tu fais la fête CX
[Musique]
escargot faut arrêter de s'attendrir com
pourrait
revenir en lui y avait appris dans sa
petite école que ses ancêtres blonds
s'appelaient lesgolois et pendant des
années il a cru sur parole lui qui est à
peu près blondc comme Henrico Matias
Titi d'autre faubour il a cherché
Gavroche mais ils se sont parfois
compris bien de travers si ses espoirs
souvent sont partis en brioche il s des
oasis au milieu du
[Musique]
désert ma patrie
y a pas monsieur corne
[Musique]
peutêre la vie c'est
la de l'auberge
[Musique]
espag queapporte ma
parole de mon si beau pays c'est pas les
hoc dog de Paris qui me rendront mon
[Musique]
apptit qui on va se taper une belle
bouffa la VI qui vient nous tend les
bras lorsque j'ai les souciis mon ami le
pied noir je m'en viens respirer dans
l'air que tu déplaces et c'esttoi
l'exider oubliant ta disgrâce qui me
donne en riant une leçon
d'espoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]